[Music]
you and I have so much to talk about
always yes thank you so much for being
here you know I we're just talking to
CeeLo I was listening yes thank you you
creep you sound like a perv
oh I was listening someone was paying
attention yes thank you yeah and you
know I'm just curious because your new
show hello ladies is sort of inspired by
your single life in raw Angeles yeah and
I'm just
I was talking to see hello about going
out obviously he's a player what's it
like for you what's it like for you when
you go out in LA well I thought you know
sort of getting on TV and doing your
talk shows and stuff but that would make
a difference it doesn't see me making a
difference I'm totally surprised that I
can't get it just Breeze into nightclubs
you know cuz I mean I'm a great dresser
like see you know I know what's going on
you know what time I try to club not
long ago it here in LA and I don't want
up to the doorman and II stood there and
as I was approaching he literally
started laughing he literally he saw me
go he just went huh no you know just be
walking by you just assume that it's
gonna get in he said he said you try I
can accompany but no no no I said wait
you went honestly I don't know if this
was a line that he'd prepared or whether
he just came out with it but he said
sorry dude but we want people in here
who look like they're gonna provide
glamour not tech support all right so
what about have you tried cuz LA can be
difficult it's you know it's back in the
day when I was dating here it was tough
stuff to do because there's so much
choice you know there's so many
beautiful people and there's I feel like
I feel like my expensive dating here is
like you're on a date with a woman and
she could and she could basically say I
love you and then just look behind you
for someone better and more attractive
but my general experience yes I'm six
foot seven it's impressive if she can
look over my shoulder do you do try to
meet people online have you tried I
never do the online thing
it's realist it's too much it's too much
now it's like it's like you can go
online you can you can meet people here
I'm from England I many people there and
then even if you get on a date there's
so much you got do you got do the dates
and you go to the theater and there's
all this machinery and it takes
months and there's I'm going to be
happier in just in medieval times you
know that mean we're just a medieval
time like the Middle Ages it was just
easier because like you know you never
you just lived in a small village you
didn't know there was another village
you just you just like married whoever
was in your village of a similar age
that wasn't dead yet worried about what
you were wearing or you'd like you do
you know Andy is there any you knows my
breath you do I mean everyone's breath
was terrible because the harvest failed
and they had to eat their dogs
you didn't go to restaurants like maybe
that you just you just married a woman
and then let your merit you met woman on
a Wednesday you were married on a Friday
and she was having kids by the following
Tuesday do exactly you had to get the
kids out before winter came and there
because they were all gone Tiger Ryan
you happier much happier you just lived
happily ever after until in a dream
world both of you got plague and dying I
was a beautiful married